BUZZ HAYS: Hi, my
name is Buzz Hays.
I'm the Global Lead of Media
and Entertainment Solutions
for Google Cloud.
And we have a very
special guest here today,
Dan Lin, who is the Vice
President of Infrastructure
Services at Viacom CBS.
We're here today to talk about
content migration strategies
to cloud.
Now, as you all
can imagine we're
experiencing some fairly
challenging market conditions
at the moment.
So a lot of media
companies are starting
to look into their archives
as a way of finding material
to monetize while
we're on a hold
pattern for other
productions to be launched.
So we have a number
of companies that
are looking into
their archives to find
content to license other
people to stream on their OTT
platforms.
And because of these
delayed content pipelines
for new productions,
there's a lot
of interest in finding
gold in these archives.
So people are looking back into
media archives of all kinds,
and that extends back
beyond digital media.
It actually extends
back into analog media,
which is something that we'll
talk a little bit about today
too.
Our definition of
media and entertainment
is everything, whether it's
film, video, audiotape,
photographs, documents,
they all qualify
and they're all finding new
relevance in this day and age.
So we find that with a
number of sports leagues,
there's a lot of
interest in trying
to leverage older content.
People love to watch
highlights of older games,
so we're finding that across
all sports, which is fantastic.
We're also seeing that there
are a number of new streaming
entities that need more content
to put onto their channels,
and legacy content is
one of the backbones
of some of the bigger studios
like Disney Plus, for example.
They have a very
extensive archive,
and they've just started to
scratch the surface, actually.
So digging into their
archives and finding ways
to monetize these older titles,
it couldn't be better timing.
Same with Apple and other
folks, like Netflix, they're
really looking for ways
to leverage older content
as we wait for newer
things to be produced.
Now, the traditional methods
of digitization and storage
are fairly laborious
and somewhat costly.
They're very labor-intensive.
So what we find
is that in cloud,
there are a number of ways
that we can help people migrate
their collections
to cloud, and that
includes media in any form.
As I mentioned, there's a lot
of analog media out there,
which is difficult to
monetize, obviously,
until it's in digital form,
until it's cleaned up,
until it's made pristine, and
made available to the public.
So we want to make
sure that we have
enough tools available
for the folks in cloud
to be able to ingest
this material,
to convert it to the
proper digital formats,
and then they can start to
bring this content to market.
As you can see here,
42% of media CIOs
are struggling with managing
their content in general.
And this is pre the
current conditions
of COVID and the environment
within which we're not
producing new content.
There's a lot of archive
content out there
that hasn't been monetized.
The analogy is like an
art museum, where over 80%
of the collection is
typically in storage
and the public never sees it.
Some of these media archives
are quite substantial,
and a lot of their material
sits behind firewalls
where people can't see it.
So now is an opportunity to
start bringing some of that
forward.
Now, there's some legacy
digitization capabilities
out there in the world.
And we need those in
order to get material
off these analog forms, like
videotape and film and audio,
for example.
Especially with film, film
is a difficult process
because it can be done in
slightly less than real time.
And videotape is
limited by the fact
that we can only
digitize in real time.
So for the 100 million
hours of videotape
that might be out there
for any given entity that
wants to digitize things, it's
going to take 100 million hours
to digitize that.
So we have some significant
challenges ahead,
but the idea is to bring
all of this material
into cloud so that it can be
then monetized and leveraged
to increase the value of these
archives as we go forward.
So as an example, we
did a project recently
with the New York Times
where we helped them
with their photo archive.
They have one of the largest
photo archives in the world,
and the archive goes back to
the beginning of photography.
And so we used a number
of our AI and ML tools
to help the New York
Times to find information
about the photographs, not
only the visual information,
but also by reading the
information that was either
handwritten or typed on
the back of the photos
about the uses,
the locations, who
might be in the photographs.
And then created a
database within which
they can search this
material at lightning speed.
So in the past, it might
take a few months for someone
to put together a
story, for example,
where they wanted
to do a photo essay
or photojournalistic exploration
of a specific subject.
They would have to
hire an archivist
to go in through
the files manually,
to find these photographs, to
find the individuals they're
talking about, which may
not be tagged appropriately,
and then send those out.
So we've gone now from
the manual process
to a much more automated process
with a very robust database,
which allows people
to really cut
the amount of time it takes
to get these stories out
to the public.
So we're seeing significant
increases in the speed
from many, many months,
now to a matter of days
to be able to
leverage the content.
So this is just one example.
Now, archive migration
within Google Cloud,
we look at it, basically,
as three distinct phases.
The first phase is the
digitization phase.
We have to get this
material into cloud.
Now, some of it may be
digital born already,
especially modern motion
pictures and television
where they're all shot
natively digitally.
In fact, most all of the
workflow itself is digital.
There are still a
few that shoot film,
but primarily it's going
to be a digital workflow.
Those files are very
easy to move to cloud,
but once you start talking
about other media types,
then the idea of
ingesting to cloud
becomes a bit more
labor-intensive.
There are more steps involved,
and we'll outline some of that
that we're helping with
in this presentation.
There's also a quality
control aspect to this.
There's a lot of
media out there.
And quality control
really requires human eyes
to really make some decisions.
So we're helping
those human eyes
by leveraging some
of the AI tools
we have so that people
can have, basically,
a checklist to go by.
So when AI finds something
that might be suspect
or some quality control
software find something suspect,
we can put a list
together and put it
in front of the people
who need to look
at this with their
own eyes and make
those decisions for themselves.
So it's a much
simpler process rather
than having people look
at every single frame
of every piece of content.
On the generate side, once we
get this material into cloud,
whether it's digitally born
or started as an analog video
tape, and then we digitize.
We create proxies for
that, which are very
important for a few reasons.
Primarily because we need
a reference copy, something
that we can look at that we
can use to search for material.
So the core of many media
asset management systems
is a proxy file, and
oftentimes the metadata
that goes along with
that is the way people
are able to search
these databases.
So we, during this phase,
leverage all of the AI and ML
tools we have to be able
to provide intelligence
to this data through what's
found in the picture,
through speech to text.
We can do sentiment
detection, we
can do celebrity recognition, we
have a number of different ways
where we can build a very
robust database, which
makes it very easy to search
these mountains of information
and make intelligent
decisions on which content
we might want to put out
there on streaming channels,
for example.
Indexing the media is
extremely important,
and we have a tool that we'll
talk a little bit about here
that's called video search,
which is a new tool that allows
us to apply all of the
machine learning and AI tools
that we have as a
single command line.
It will then build a database
of all of this metadata,
and then we can
surface that data
through a search API that could
be leveraged within whatever
application people want to use.
So say, for example,
you're an editor
and you work in Adobe Premiere
or in Avid or in Black Magic
Resolve.
You can now leverage
the search capability
within the application
itself, which
means you no longer have to
rely on going to a media asset
management system, finding
the clips you're looking for,
exporting those clips,
then reimporting
those clips into your editing
system just to use them.
Now you can surface those clips
directly within the application
that you want to
process the files with.
And it makes it for a much more
efficient process, much faster.
And because we use natural
language processing,
you'll now find things that
you thought weren't there
or you weren't asking
for them correctly,
so you were getting
incorrect responses.
There's no more
Boolean search required
to find the value in the media.
So this idea of indexing
media is extremely important,
especially when you
have a lot of it.
And the archive itself is
only as good as this index.
So we have many customers
who have many, many petabytes
of media out there,
and some of it
is multiple versions
of the same thing.
It could be localized versions
of a given title, for example,
all the different foreign
language versions of something.
But it's difficult
sometimes when
you have these massive
archives to know
where there's duplication.
So we have a lot of ways to
be able to detect duplication
and help call out some of
this derivative material
so that you can make the
footprint of your archives
much more manageable,
if you will.
And then we also talk
about preservation storage.
We have a number
of strategies we
talk about creating
preservation masters,
especially for
videotape, where we
can remove all of the
compression codecs
for both the audio
and the video,
so we can have a true
archive representation
of that media that could
be read in the future.
And then finally,
the third phase
of what we talk about
with archive migration
has to do with how we
leverage all of these assets.
And so I'll talk a little bit
more about that in a second.
So as I mentioned, we have all
these different types of media,
whether it's film or
videotape, audiotape, we
have lots of media on
data tape right now,
both LTO and T10K and some other
older formats like DLT, DAT.
So there's media
all over the place.
And so trying to
get that stuff off
of this legacy media,
which is non-archival,
to bring it into cloud, which is
archival, and make sense of it
is one of our key missions when
it comes to this digitization
phase.
Then when it comes to
generating the assets' metadata,
we use the various tools we
have in our AI and ML toolset.
As you can see here, we generate
the proxies, as I mentioned.
We index that media.
And it's all fairly
automated, so when
you have a massive
collection you
can have a very substantial
database that can be searched
very quickly using natural
language processing to find
the material you're looking
for without really any hiccups.
And then finally,
leveraging the content,
especially to get
this to the public.
We find that the
metadata is actually
very useful in
direct-to-consumer plays
where people are looking
for a specific thing.
They may not be able to
remember the actor's name,
but they might remember the
character's name in the show.
So all of this metadata
can travel along
with the media that would make
it easier for the consumers
to find what they're
looking for, just
like the power of
a Google search.
And then, of course,
our ecosystem
wouldn't be the
same if we didn't
have all these great
partners to deal with.
So we have all of these
wonderful content management
and archive migration partners
that we work with regularly
to help leverage the ways
we search this media,
the way we tag the media,
the way we store the media.
So we spend a lot of time
with our various customers
and these partners to
really integrate and find
the best solutions for
folks to be able to manage
their massive media archives.
Now, today we have
a very special guest
with Dan Lin from Viacom CBS.
And they are
leveraging, at Viacom,
they're leveraging Google Cloud
Advanced Analytics to enhance
their content discovery.
And they have lots of media
from lots of different sources.
And so Dan is here to talk
a little bit about that.
But I just want to point out
a couple of key things here.
Certainly with the
content recommendations,
there are over 4.2
million customers per day
looking for recommendations.
It's possible now to
provide actionable insights
for both marketing
and the ads teams
to be able to analyze, in this
case, 2,500 pieces of content
daily.
And we deliver in-house
solutions for AI and ML,
which help leverage Google
Cloud products with just
a few developers in-house.
So leveraging the
power of AutoML
and some of the other
partner tools we have,
people now have the power of
ML training their own models
without having to
be data scientists.
So without further ado, I'd
like to introduce our very
special guest, Dan Lin.
DAN LIN: Thank you, Buzz,
for the introduction.
So I'm going to walk through
a little bit about one
of the projects that
we did with Google.
It's part of a
much bigger journey
that Viacom CBS is undertaking
through our journey
to the cloud.
This project that we did
with Google is specifically
around Viacom's content.
Viacom CBS has a lot
of different content,
both on the television and film.
In the case of film,
it's Paramount Pictures.
So this project that
we're working on
is specifically
around the Viacom.
So what we're trying
to do, I'm going
to walk you through a little
bit of project overview,
and talk a little bit
about the business
requirement and the architecture
and how we accomplish this.
So first, the project overview.
So we have roughly 17
petabytes of content,
and these content, like
what Buzz has mentioned,
is a lot of our source content.
And where all the
derivative assets
are generated to
for, ultimately,
for distribution and
packaging to multiple partners
and suppliers, and then
vendors and so forth.
So we call this the
content submission master.
So the idea of
this cloud journey
is to move all these
submission masters,
or at least make a copy of
it, and put it in the cloud
so that can be easily consumed.
So it's a relatively early part
of the content supply chain.
And once we are able to put
all these content in the cloud,
then it'll be readily
available for transformation
or distribution, and
so on and so forth,
and as well as all
other AI and ML things
that we like to do
with these contents
that we weren't able
to do before on prem.
So let me talk a little bit
about the business requirement
for the cloud migration.
So the total amount
of assets we were
talking about for this
project was about 14 petabytes
of content.
And we need to do this in
roughly a four-month period.
Besides moving a copy of
the content to the cloud,
we needed to make sure that the
data integrity is maintained.
And there's really two
parts to the data integrity.
One is making sure
that the content that
while during the
transfer process
is not manipulated
and is identical
to the original source.
So that's one aspect
of the integrity.
The second aspect is that
the inventory is complete.
Right.
So we did not miss anything.
So every single piece
of content that we're
supposed move to the cloud,
copy, made it to Google.
Lastly, if there's
any exceptions
as a part of that transfer,
we all, of course,
need to be able to easily
identify those and then
remediate them accordingly.
So some of the key questions
that we needed to address
is, what's the best
way to move that data
in that short amount of time?
And there's a couple of
things that we looked at.
One was TSOP, which is basically
the Google Transfer tool.
Another method we looked
at was Transfer Appliance,
which is where they're shipping,
essentially, large hard drives,
and then we have to put
into the data center,
move the data onto
these hard drives,
and then ship them
back to Google,
and then Google will suck
it into the Google Cloud.
And then the last
option is the gsutil,
which is a command line option.
Other things that we have
to make decisions about--
where do we store it,
what tier do we store it?
Obviously, depending on the
tier and so on so forth,
and where we store it has
different cost implications.
Lastly is how do we
protect the data?
This data is the
source asset, so we
need to make sure it does not
get unauthorized access or gets
tampered, and so on so forth.
So how do we go about
protecting this data?
And some different types of
aspects of that data protection
is, do we turn on
things like versioning?
Do we end up using bucket lock
or object lock, [INAUDIBLE]
not choosing to do.
As well as who has access, and
that's basically the IAM roles.
Lastly, from the
requirement point of view,
we also want to make sure
this can be done relatively
easily with minimum labor.
Just because, again, Viacom CBS
is a very large content media
company.
We have a lot of
content, and this is just
the first one of many.
So we want to make sure that
this process and the tool
that we chose are efficient.
And another part
is that whatever
software we choose to
use to do this transfer
and manage a transfer, and so
on so forth, as new requirements
come up new features can
be added, can be deployed
and so on so forth.
And so that's where the
automated code deployment
comes in.
So, essentially, all these
data are on LTL tapes,
and it's actually being
supported by [? DBA. ?] So we
actually, basically, need
to pull all these data out
of [? DBA ?] from [INAUDIBLE],,
which was acquired by Oracle,
and I think lately it also
spun out to EcoDigital.
It's a fairly popular
[? MAM ?] system
that's used across many,
many media and entertainment
companies.
We're going to loaded it
onto a local SAN storage,
and we're going to
use, essentially,
the TSOP software to eventually
move these data to Google.
So the primary
consideration on why
we chose TSOP was
basically that TSOP handles
a lot of the management
for us, especially in terms
of validating, making
sure the data--
the integrity is maintained,
that is relatively easy
to operate.
There's not a lot
of people that need
to get involved in staging or
destaging equipment and what
have you, or loading
and unloading data
into physical equipment, in the
case of the Transfer Appliance.
And so TSOP was
the obvious choice.
It has a combination
of ease of use
and least amount of manual
intervention required.
And so that's why
we picked TSOP.
So beyond using
the TSOP, the TSOP
just basically handles
the data transfer.
I'm going to talk a little
bit about those architecture.
What's important is that when
we're moving all this data out
of [? DBA, ?] obviously,
is carry over some
of the proprietary things that's
specific to [? DBA. ?] Part
of what we want to do in the
process is not carry any sort
of technical debt.
So information that's very
specific to [? DBA, ?]
for example, how objects are
referenced and so on and so
forth.
We want to change
the architecture such
that we're using for a
more native GUIs that
more conforms to
modern architecture.
So not only do we do
the data transfer,
we actually did a
lot of manipulation
in terms of file names
and so on so forth.
So that by the time
it gets to Google
it doesn't have any of the
historical information that's
specific to [? DBA. ?]
So one of things that happened,
you'll see this workflow,
I won't cover all of it, but
you'll see all the other things
that we did by leveraging
things like BigQuery
and some custom stuff that's
written to basically do
all these manipulation
and processing.
[INAUDIBLE] with
TSOP was how we were
able to manage the whole
data migration to Google.
So with that, this
is the conclusion
of this particular project.
We were able to achieve
this in four months.
One of the key
reasons that I think
is worth pointing out
why we chose Google out
of all the other vendors,
that there are two key things
that we thought that set
the Google, especially
the S3 storage, apart.
One, is the fact
that, regardless
of the tier or storage, the
access is always instantaneous.
Whereas, some of
the other providers,
you store it on
coder tier and you
need that piece of
information, it's
not necessarily instantaneous.
The second thing that we
thought made Google stand out
in this use case was
the fact that there
is a special continental bucket
that we were able to store to.
So in a scenario where we
have assets that we need
protected and have multiple
copies, for example.
So that's not subject
to localized failures.
We do not necessarily need to
make full copies, for example,
to availability zones or
regions or what have you.
There's a concept of
a continental region.
So, effectively, that will allow
us to achieve that requirement,
but without having to pay
double to copy, essentially,
with another provider.
So those are actually
the key reasons
why we picked Google
for this project.
So in summary, we were able
to achieve this in four months
with a lot of help from Google,
it was a great partnership.
This is the first of many
content library migrations,
and as we speak,
we are now moving
on to the next one, which
is Paramount Pictures.
BUZZ HAYS: Thank you, Dan.
That's great, and it's
a very nice description
of how you did this.
As you can see, this
is representative
of how Viacom CBS is managing
their massive archives.
But, Dan, in your
experience, you
pointed out a couple
of things here
I wanted to ask you
a little bit about.
It's the integrity checks,
the checksums, part of this.
It's an extremely important
part of any of these archives.
And if you talk
to any archivist,
whether they refer to it
as a checksum, an MD5 hash
or [INAUDIBLE],,
everyone is concerned
about checking the
file integrity of what
those files are as
they're stored in a cloud.
So could you talk a little
bit about that process?
Is that a fully
automated process
that's part of your
[? MAM, ?] or how do
the checksums happen over time?
DAN LIN: Yes, it definitely is.
So the way we do it today, like
you said, a lot of this stuff
is stored on LTL, so LTL has
the lifecycle, essentially,
if you will.
So we have a business
requirement where every year
we're actually pulling
back every piece of asset
and rehashing, basically,
read the content into memory
and comparing the MD5
against the original source.
And that's how we make
sure nothing got changed.
And, obviously, they're
saying that doesn't match,
and new copies get created.
And most of the time
when things don't match,
it's due to bit rot
or what have you.
So it definitely does
occur, especially
given the amount of
content that we have.
Obviously, in the grand scheme
of the population of content
we have, the amount of bit rot
is actually very, very small,
but we want to make sure
we're catching those
so that we always have
confidence in our content.
Especially on the film side,
which the content sometimes
maybe can take hundreds of
millions of dollars to make.
We definitely want to make
sure those contents are not
contaminated in any fashion.
BUZZ HAYS: Yeah, that's
a very good point,
because a lot of the archived
media that's been used to date
is somewhat fragile, right?
And so I imagine
prior to this you
had to have a migration strategy
to get from, for example,
one LTL format to
the next one, just
to be able to preserve the
archive at some cadence.
But now, once you've
moved things to cloud,
I think that you can
breathe a sigh of relief
that you don't have to do
those migrations anymore.
But this also speaks
to one question
I had is about with a
company as big as Viacom CBS,
you're dealing with a number of
different libraries or archives
from different entities.
And it seems that those
can be somewhat uniform
within the company, even
though the assets came
from disparate locations.
They probably came with
all manner of metadata--
or no metadata, who knows.
But are you seeing
this as an opportunity
to create a uniform database
of all of this media
that you now have
within Viacom CBS?
DAN LIN: Yeah, that's
definitely the idea.
I mean, it runs the gamut.
I mean, typically,
the amount of metadata
that we have and
maintain it's really
a function of multiple things.
But one thing that it
definitely very much aligned to
is the value of the asset.
Typically, the more
valuable the asset,
the more effort was put into
maintaining the metadata
and cataloging in the content.
We also have content
that's prefinished work
as part of production
process, or what have you.
Especially 10 years
ago, 20 years ago,
again, not having the
digital, so obviously
the level of catalog varies.
So as we migrate more and
more stuff to the cloud
and we're leveraging
things like AI and ML
to do things like automated
video and audio conformance
and what have you, there's
also a lot of opportunity
to do auto metadata
tagging and so forth.
Again, a lot of
our legacy content
that maybe doesn't have the same
amount of richness in metadata.
And as we do more
and more of this,
we will hopefully
be able to monetize.
I didn't find new
[INAUDIBLE] how
to use, especially
content that we
haven't touched in a long time.
BUZZ HAYS: Yeah.
And to that point,
final question,
is you mentioned the notion of
the different tiers of storage
we have at Google,
and how your retrieval
times are the same time to
first byte on each tier.
In my experience, I'm noticing
that a lot of companies have--
their archive is
not a static thing,
it's an actual living
breathing thing,
and you're constantly
finding ways
to monetize what's in there.
Is that part of the strategy
at this point with Viacom CBS,
is to start leveraging some
of the older content that's
been sitting in the archive that
may not have been as visible
or as searchable in the past?
DAN LIN: Yeah.
I mean, it really
runs the gamut.
I mean, again, we have things
that are like the raw--
and on the film side
and the television side
it's actually quite different.
On the film side
we have things that
are, for example, preservation
master, which were
the original raw DPX files.
We probably won't be
necessarily working
a lot against
those type of files
per se, right, in that space.
We will probably use
like a mezzanine format.
So legacy sort of
mezzanine sort of content
that we might do the things
that you're talking about.
But who knows, right?
In five years or
10 years, the thing
that seems to be
relatively constant
is that the quality of
the content that people
want to seem to work again just
keeps going higher and higher.
So maybe somewhere
down the road we
might be working directly
against the original
preservation masters.
BUZZ HAYS: That's great.
Well, Dan, thank you,
again, for your time today.
Thank you for
contributing to this,
and thank you for
working with us.
This has been such
a great project
and we look forward
to many, many more.
And thank you all
for listening, and I
hope you found this
useful and entertaining.
And expect more to come from
Viacom CBS and Google Cloud.